madame la rapporteur général
oui mais
[Musique]
président de
tempête en cas de dommage sur les lignes
électriques sur les canalisations
gazières je voudrais aussi associer à
cet hommage tous ceux qui interviennent
pour la maintenance du réseau et qui
sont des sous-traitants
sur les travaux de maintenance
80% sont réalisés par des sous-traitants
ils n'ont pas du tout de régime spécial
eux
alors je voudrais aussi indiquer que ce
régime concerne
135427 cotisants et qu'il y a plus de
180 000 pensionnés et c'est là où est le
déséquilibre en réalité et l'État
intervient donc pour 5 pour 3
3141 millions d'euros donc 3 milliards
141 donc c'est quand même important sur
cinq virgule 184 milliards d'euros c'est
énorme donc on peut se dire à partir de
là que c'est sans doute normal que on se
pose la question d'aller vers la
fermeture de ce risque vieillesse et je
le rappelle sur tous les autres risques
ça reste le régime spécial
de la caisse pour national des
industries
électriques et gazières je voudrais
aussi dire que certains ont parlé de
l'excédent mais l'excédent c'est la
contribution tarifaire et donc ça chacun
d'entre nous y contribue donc pour
toutes ces raisons
nous avons émis un avis défavorable
puisque les propositions des amendements
sont contraires à la vie de la
Commission
monsieur le ministre
mais merci monsieur le Président
gouvernement fait si l'intégralité des
propos de madame le rapporteur général
et donc la vie est défavorable je
voudrais simplement amener trois
compléments le premier pour dire que
parfois dans les explications sur les
présentations de l'amendement il est
évoqué
sous-entendu mais le terme n'est pas le
mieux choisi donc je fais attention
qu'il y aurait une rupture du pacte
social or je le répète au risque de la
répétition par définition nous
maintenons les régimes spéciaux pour
celles et ceux qui en bénéficient et
seuls les nouveaux embauchés à partir du
1er septembre seront affiliés au régime
général de l'assurance vieillesse c'est
important à souligner pour bien dire que
toutes celles et ceux qui imaginent ou
qui laisse penser que demain l'ensemble
des salariés des IEG n'auraient pu le
régime social ne sont pas dans le vrai
sont uniquement les nouveaux qui vont
l'être et cela m'amène à un point qui a
été évoqué rapidement notamment sur les
conséquences de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler ce tarissement du flux par
rapport à un système social qui doit
gérer les retraités actuels et celles et
ceux qui gagneront leur retraite sous
couvert toujours de ce régime spécial
nous l'avons déjà fait pour la SNCF et
lorsque nous avons mis en place
l'extinction du statut pour le coup pas
seulement du régime général de pas
seulement du régime d'assurance
vieillesse pour la SNCF nous avons
garanti le financement de la SNCF et de
la même manière que nous avons garanti
le financement de la SNCF bien
évidemment que nous garantirons la
soutenabilité du financement de du
régime de retraite des industries
électriques et gazières la deuxième
chose que je voulais dire au souligner
et que à plusieurs reprises sur ce sujet
là en particulier a été évoqué le fait
que ce régime avait été mis en place
dans la libération et qui relevait
finalement de l'héritage du Conseil
National de la Résistance il relève en
réalité très directement de l'ordonnance
du 4 octobre 1945 et cette ordonnance du
4 octobre 1945 qui vient acter la
création des régimes spéciaux de manière
générale précise de manière explicite
que cette création provisoire et que
l'objectif est d'aller vers le régime
général et donc lorsqu'on veut prendre
l'héritage de cette période et notamment
sur les textes il faut aller jusqu'au
bout des textes et peut-être que c'est
d'ailleurs en allant progressivement
vers un régime général que nous y sommes
le plus fidèle et enfin il y a un
dernier point que je veux souligner
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'excédent il peut
y avoir parfois telle ou telle année des
renversements mais un régime qui
s'équilibre et un régime qui produit de
légers excédents alors qu'il bénéficie
d'une contribution payée par l'ensemble
des usagers l'ensemble des clients
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des abonnés à
hauteur d'un milliard 700 millions
d'euros par an ça n'est pas un régime
équilibré parce qu'évidemment si tous
les régimes particuliers bénéficiaient
d'une taxe affectée parce que je précise
pour la bonne compréhension du débat
qu'il y a des jurisprudences qu'il y a
des dispositions législatives qui
précisent que la CTA est bien une taxe
affectée lorsqu'un régime bénéficie
d'une taxe affectée il est plus facile
que ce régime atteigne l’équilibre mais
ça s'appelle le financement de la
solidarité par les contribuables et donc
pour ces raisons un succès de madame le
rapporteur les avis sont défavorables
ces amendements de suppression merci
[Musique]